you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and I'm going to go
through three puzzles and simply share
my thoughts along the way so we're
playing as white in this first one and I
imagine we can win oh I just spotted the
idea fortunately for me a puzzle that I
went through just a little while back
just the other day really is helping me
out with this one we have this idea
where we can give a check on a eight and
on King take say a rook a six is mate
this is the idea that I saw just the
other day this is not the only option
but of course one of the options is king
takes rook we would give me has the
follow-up the only other option after
rook a eight his queen takes a eight and
then we're in a position to relocate our
rook to I don't know that it really
would matter I believe we could go to b3
b2 or b1 with the idea of playing to a3
for me I don't see how black stops that
so I'm pretty sure this is the idea to
first give this check we know the Queen
has to take otherwise we have me so I'm
just trying to work out now is there a
difference between these through these
three posts b3 b2 b1 notice with the
Queen on the corner after the rook
placed let's say b3 there isn't a good
Queen move that would give check and
disrupt our our king's post so is there
a difference after the black queen is
here we're no longer playing with this
guy rook b3 rook b2
there is a difference with b2 because
the Queen could play back to d5 and
defend against rook a - so I'm
eliminating be two of these three so now
it's down to B 3 and B 1 is there
difference there well there is a
difference actually because on be one
there is Queen to h8 stopping rook a 1
so therefore it's going to be rook to be
3 this would have been my first thought
of these 3 well it was my first thought
because this pawn masks the Queen from
defending a3 along this diagonal so it
must be b3 rook e8 and Queen takes rook
and then rook to b3 and there's no
stopping this rook aids-free move for
long okay
let's put it on board rooks sacrifice I
have my sounds on let's take care of
that b3 is the key move and then we're
gonna scoop up the Queen is this gonna
be played out further and they're gonna
test us how we hunt down this pawn I
don't think so
yeah it should just be puzzle solved it
wouldn't really be any anything close if
I'm to just bring it up this final
position this was the starting position
so where we got rook b3 King here
if it was to play out we'd get our King
involved and just the rook right behind
and it's gonna take forever and we're
gonna be there in time to track this
pawn down okay let's try puzzle number
two I kind of lucked out with this first
one seeing this idea recently with the
rook sacrifice okay
as black and we are in check okay we
have three options King e7 and bishop or
rook captures on d7 how are we doing
materialize were balanced completely
okay it's worth noting that we have some
pressure on this rook so normally a move
like this would be something to shy away
from our first glance at least because
of a knight move with the discovered
check but King e7 and Knight move we
could just take the rook and
hmm yeah it's probably that cuz if we
take with the rook well we're gonna be
losing some material Knight takes and if
we take with the bishop hmm maybe we
could do that let's consider I'm gonna
look at this one first it's if you it's
more forceful captures a piece Bishop
takes Knight you have rook takes Bishop
we would then have Bishop takes Knight
removing the defender of the rook and
unrep takes rook Bishop takes rook and
in the end we're up a minor piece
therefore Bishop takes Knight Knight
takes and then maybe only at that point
do we play King here the rook is under
fire and so too is the knight on D 7 I
think it's important to first eliminate
one of the Knights and I possibly the
reason for this is because I'm king e7
immediately with there being a knight on
f6 there's Knight g8 well and that's one
of the moves to calculate there's Knight
g8 check as well as Knight to d5 I'm
gonna say that it's just this it seems a
lot cleaner just eliminate a piece that
takes King here and I don't see what the
good move is the rook is under fire the
Knights under fire I don't see any
problem with just grabbing the knight
and now we just grab the knight here and
defend our rook and we're gonna be up a
minor piece okay not too bad for number
2 let's try one more where we are
playing as black and I feel like we
should be giving mate somehow this has
my attention we're controlling a lot of
the squares around the white King and we
are opposite the queen who is
unprotected so this may play a role um I
actually think I know what opening this
came from like some for Knights opening
yeah
I think like the night f3 to g5 stuff
and d5 was played white was really quick
to converge on f7 and then there was a
retreat anyhow and I'll have the exact
moves but I'm pretty sure King pawn
opening for Knights Knight g5 stuff is
where this came from so what should we
do here if it's White's move they don't
have a good check any Bishop move is
threatening Queen f2 mate
this is something I imagine the King is
quite secure if the I mean there's a
check here but other than that I don't
see how else to really disrupt the king
position beyond the f2 square so there's
this check immediately there's queen f2
if move one is a bishop move wouldn't
white just have time to play rook f1 and
defend against f2 what would be our
follow up after that suppose I don't
know Bishop b6 it's not very forcing I
don't think at least it opens up f2 rook
f1 now what I don't see it
I wonder if we could do something like
rook g1 this would interfere with rook F
1rx to me Bishop Bishop g1 would
interfere with rook F 1 by Bishop g1
there's rook takes and if we give check
on F 2 there's now a new square for the
King as soon as the rook moves okay is
there a way that we could get the King
in a position where we couldn't make a
knight move and pick up the Queen hmm
like a check on G
five hmm no no no it's kind of tough to
force the King to f1 I mean we could
give this check King f1 but then what
are we doing there hmm
would it really be a quiet move on move
to Queen g5 King f1 Queen f4 threatening
Knight g3 threatening Knight d2 width
check and as well as a bishop move
looking to get to f2 next that may be it
hmm I have some concern though even over
the variation with Queen g5 King f3 not
quite sure what I'm doing there
Queen f4 King back to G - what are we
doing if the king is on g2 and our queen
is on f4 no
find some other candidate moves besides
Queen g5 to be honest I don't think it's
a bishop move on move one yeah it needs
to be something tied in with the Sun
protected piece on a4 how can we make
that happen I don't see it
g3 there's nothing really happening on
g3 we have a few pieces it's one of
these one of those intersection squares
but I don't see how we could really make
use of that mm-hmm
I don't see how this night contributes
either rook it's got to be one of these
three the King position looking for mate
and something with the Queen how we
doing materialized I didn't even take a
body count here four five six even hmm
let's revisit this Queen g5 and King f3
I think I think the answer would be
after King F one King g5 King
excuse me Queen g5 King F one Queen f4
is pretty convincing although I mean Y
could revisit this King G to mo so I
need to figure out what to do if we have
this same exact position but with the
Queen on f4 what would blacks move be
because we could get exactly that in two
moves what would we do there would fish
up g1 work in that position I don't
think so
still not seeing what the story would be
after if it takes Bishop so what we give
a check on F to the King goes to the
corner whether it be a climb of in that
position with Queen takes Bishop looking
at night f2 maybe
hmm mm maybe that's it
and Bishop g1 unmoved one rook takes
Queen F to king h1 and then we pick up
the bishop threatening night F to check
and then a knight move with the
discovered check hmm oh you know or even
threatening maybe in some cases with the
Queen on e2 we're threatening a check on
f3 rook block night f2 check King g1
h3 check King h1 Queen f3 we are
threatening mate after we take that
bishop in this position here
Bishop g1 rook takes Queen f2 King in
the corner Queen takes Bishop we're
threatening and me in 1 2 3 4 5
how would white parry that no we don't
worry about any of these guys just
helping it also we can't afford a client
move in other words Bishop g1 rook takes
basically just this move to be assured
we can get to f2 next to stop
rook f1 so with our queen on e - how
would white parry our threat of going
into f2 Queen here is not a bother
because we just go to f2 and defend and
I don't see how the Queen actually helps
out in defending against these main
threats the rook has step up to g2 but
we it's still gonna be a mate we can
revisit f1 force King force rook g1 and
then get back to this f3 Queen f3 Knight
f2 night h3 Queen f1 Queen g1 stuff I
think this is it it is clean f2 and it's
important to recognize that we can get
to this point here where it's gonna be
mate soon yeah so white has to give up
the Queen there wasn't a defense to the
knight in Queen going after the White
King in that final position mmm that was
tricky this first position
Angie - yes seems like it's the only
thing
take the bishop you know just to just
illustrate I mean I don't even know what
to do with the White Queen just to show
the mating idea rook is pinned that's a
check and then we got this stuff that
wasn't even the only one we have our
pick to go here for me
Queen Knight tandem is super strong hmm
have to give up the Queen here to stop
paint
there's no no way to provide a new
square for the White King yeah this is
really strong knight on e5 Queen here
looking to get on the diagonal strong
combination of pieces here okay
interesting group of three feel free as
usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below and
as always I hope you got something out
of it that's all for now take care bye
you